l'argomento è tosto e difficile
ascoltiamo ascoltavo prima giuliano e mi
immaginavo anche qual è l'approccio
giusto quando si parla di un tema così
complicato complicato perché si corre
sempre il rischio di di far diventare un
intervento una lezione un dibattito
teorico qualcosa di lontano soprattutto
quando si parla di economia quando si
parla di imprese quando si parla di
numeri allora ho cercato in un argomento
così difficile come il fallimento di
raccontarvi delle storie alcune storie
collegandoli con i numeri perché
ovviamente quando si parla di economia
quando si parla di mondo imprenditoriali
il numero è imprescindibile ma cercando
di raccontarvi qualcosa che vi possa far
capire quanto dietro il numero ci siano
delle persone
allora partiamo da alcune esperienze
vere di quello che è capitato in questi
anni nel ruolo di trovarmi di fronte al
mio ufficio a delle persone come stavo
raccontando due persone specifiche
marito e moglie imprenditori in ufficio
sono di fronte a me lei e agli occhi
fissi lui anche un po un po commosso
sono in silenzio la domanda che sorge
ma com'è possibile come è stato
possibile
fabrizio e anna sono due imprenditori
lui è un classe 1958 a un'azienda che la
sua famiglia dei suoi zii a un bel
capannone non troppo grande e un
appartamento adiacente al capannone a
quattro dipendenti produce infissi in
legno in pvc
l'aziendina sana ma era un'azienda
un'azienda che ha attraversato la crisi
dell'edilizia la crisi che dal 2008 fino
a adesso in realtà ha falciato centinaia
e centinaia e migliaia di imprese
il fronte invece sono delle persone
imprenditori dei numeri le loro famiglie
e il concetto di fallimento che
ritornerà in tutto questo tocca il fatto
di capi
perché ma cos'è il fallimento
fondamentalmente è un argomento che si è
anche fortemente voluto in questi dieci
anni dalle poche esperienze dalle pochi
fallimenti imprenditoriali di alcuni
anni fa appunto a una eccessiva
frequenza e quindi la stessa normativa
le stessa le stesse regole le stesse
paletti che ci danno un aiuto da potestà
legislativa sono mutati addirittura
quest'anno stesso con un decreto
specifico che sarà più che altro ad
aiutare in termini normativi a far
emergere gli elementi per aiutare chi
sta in difficoltà chi è in crisi più che
fallire la crisi finanziaria crisi di
flusso economico e il tentativo
ovviamente neanche di indirizzarlo
meglio perché negli occhi di fabrizio
anna non c'è soltanto il fallimento
della propria attività c'è un fallimento
della propria vita
qui ha voluto mettere alcuni numeri
perché di numeri ogni tanto bisogna
parlare quando li ho visti
qualcuno può pensare 45 78 67
ecco uno per dire beh non sono numeri
importanti per un territorio che questo
probabilmente è alta è un errore perché
sono persone dentro quelle imprese ci
sono altre persone
negli ultimi dieci anni sono scomparse
più di 4mila imprese del territorio
ferrarese da 39.000 iscritti alla camera
commercio del 2008 ai 35.000 del 31
dicembre ogni anno negli ultimi 12 anni
c'è un saldo negativo tra imprese che
cessano le imprese che aprono e sono
persone sono fabrizio e sono anna allora
bisogna diciamo anche per capire lo
stato d'animo di fabrizia capire anche
in che campo di gioco noi giochiamo
qual è il nostro contesto ho cercato di
dargli un significato un messaggio
l'italia torri campana e piccole imprese
perché il nostro campo di gioco è di
fabrizio anno il nostro campo di gioco è
di quell'impresa di 4 dipendenti il
nostro campo di gioco sono quelle
aziende che sotto i 20 dipendenti
sono la nostra quotidianità ma che
significherà la quotidianità significa
che il 98.2 per cento di tutte le realtà
economiche sono sotto i 20 dipendenti
questo siamo noi questa è l'italia da
lavora otto milioni di persone il 56 per
cento e per avere dei confronti sul
nostro campo di gioco con la francia la
germania qualche paese vicino a noi
se noi diamo lavoro tramite queste
imprese a quasi il 57 per cento appunto
in francia e 34 e il 30 per cento in
germania
noi siamo così noi siamo realtà piccole
noi abbiamo un'economia di prossimità
allora uno avrebbe da dire cavolo se
sono così tante si sono così diffuse
sono dappertutto
beh allora piccola è facile piccolo è
bello piccolo e semplice non è così
e anche per questo fabrizio e anna sono
seduti a me e mi chiedono come mai
perché nella loro testa sanno che non è
facile
sanno che ogni comune diverso che ogni
province diverse che ogni regione
diversa che per le loro attività c'è
sempre qualcosa che continuamente to
affronti chi li ha resi difficilmente
sereni e quindi non è vero addirittura
comune che vai burocrazia che trovi ti
verrebbe da dire semplificazione è una
bella novità questo è un argomento
fresco come qualcuno negli ultimi 29
anni sono succeduti otto legislature 16
governi 19 ministri tutti
tutti hanno parlato di semplificazione
tutti eppure e poi siamo così siamo di
fronte a fabrizio anna c'è bisogno di
una legge apposta per aiutarli in un
momento di difficoltà beh allora
parlavamo di difficoltà e uno può
pensare e se volesse aprire e se volesse
chiudere la mia attività è a questo
punto aprire qualcos'altro fare qualche
altro tipo di lavoro lo sommato o delle
competenze o anche voglio anche energia
o passione è uno pensa potrebbe aprire
visto che 98.2 per cento di imprese sono
piccole qualcosa di facile potrebbe
aprire un bar qualcosa di così
per up in ombra ci vogliono 72
adempimenti 72 adempimenti che sono
diverse a comune a comune la provincia
provincia
15 mila euro solo per partire enti
realtà con cui devi dialogare più volte
e quindi fabrizia che sono in difficoltà
qualcosa pensa neanche di questo per
ritrasformarsi il mio campo di gioco e
un campo di gioco difficile e infangato
gioco con fatica forse sono stato
sfortunato e ve l'ho detto a prendere un
bar
probabilmente è una delle attività più
difficili proviamo a fare qualcosa di
più semplice qualcosa anche di diverso
un autoriparatore 86 c'è una cosa che
non torna
sono cose non va quindi o fabrizio anna
o difficoltà e per aprire difficile
quindi da dove ripartire noi dobbiamo
ripartire da quello che siamo e quello
che la nostra identità da quello che la
nostra storia e quindi per cercare di
capire quello che siamo quello che ci
circonda
ma io parlerò anche di cose piuttosto
semplice hobby la nostra storia il 98.2
per cento il valore aggiunto che
all'italia un valore aggiunto di
intelligenza di intelletto di realtà di
prossimità punto e quindi è a questo
punto beh uno strumento di grande aiuto
sono le associazioni di categoria nata
nel 1946 da sempre una realtà italiana
che ci distingue perché questo perché
c'è in tutti i comuni tutte le province
in tutte le regioni di qualsiasi cosa in
qualsiasi genere è uno strumento uno
strumento di relazione
una palestra per i più giovani per
quelli che devono saper giocare in un
campo di gioco difficile per quelli che
devono saper andare correre con gli
scarponi in un campo di gioco difficile
perché c'è bisogno di innovazione c'è
bisogno di tecnologia c'è bisogno di
credito c'è bisogno di formazione
continua costante e poi è poi questo non
basta
non c'è sufficienza c'è bisogno anche di
strutture di reti si reti di imprese un
argomento anche questo piuttosto noto
comune mare di flessibile la capacità di
mettersi in rete cup partendo sempre la
nostra identità
si è parlato prima di leonardo della
nostra storia del nostro s come diceva è
anche prima simone del mondo agricolo
artigiani nel nostro valore e quindi
quindi reti che possono dare valore
aggiunto in termini intellettuali ma con
una produzione anche lontana in che modo
probabilmente anche intervenendo sul
campo di gara il campo di gioco di cui
parlavo prima
intorno a noi abbiamo aree produttive
che sono nate intorno agli anni 50 agli
anni 70 non vanno più bene e dobbiamo
cambiare non costruire cambiare è un
altro gioco quello di oggi è un altro
pallone quindi in quelle aree c'è
bisogno di tecnologia di smart i servizi
di innovazione io posso lavorare in
termini di territorialità qui a ferrara
come possono essere a piacenza come
possa essere a cagliari e nel frattempo
dialogare con imprese realtà a berlino a
londra da tutte le parti
io sono i valore aggiunto dall'altra
parte c'è la produzione io lavoro con il
mio terreno con il mio territorio
io sono economia e di prossimità
nella mia zona e mi piace provare anche
a chiudere un ragionamento in questi
termini partendo sempre da quello che
abbiamo visto prima la fabrizio danna da
quello che hanno vissuto e da questa
voglia di cambiamento anche con degli
esempi precisi con esempi pratici ma ho
voluto pensare a un amico a un
imprenditore a qualcuno che ha fatto
un'attività diversa a matteo e matteo è
un professionista che ha aperto
un'attività con altri professionisti la
ubicata non un luogo qualsiasi
all'interno di un incubatore innovativo
un ex caserma quindi una struttura che è
stata riqualificata e che cosa fa
matteo matteo è un po il continuo di
fabrizio non fa più infissi non fa
finestre fa stampi in 3d materiali
innovativo che poi si è tentato da per
tutti in qualsiasi contesto
ma fa anche qualcosa di ancora oltre e
questo è per me un valore aggiunto
matteo dà la possibilità di far
rinascere quello che è stato distrutto
in questo caso in questo esempio è un
esempio preciso è la ricostruzione di un
pezzo di un
di un tempio del soffitto di un tempio
del dio bel a palmira distrutto nel 2015
dall'isis dai guerriglieri e deciso non
esiste più eppure il team di matteo in
questo caso ha riprodotto un pezzo la
nostra storia consentendoci di poterlo
vivere innovazione qualcosa che non
c'era
con fabrizio e con anna ma che hanno
fatto
e qui è stato anche premiato dal
presidente mattarella mi piace terminare
questo mio intervento quando avevo
parlato di fabrizio aveva parlato di
numeri hanno parlato di campo di gioco
abbiamo parlato velocemente
dell'economia cercando di non scendere
dettaglio ma c'è nelle ricette un
concetto importante senza il quale come
riceva prima simone ma anche il sale
il valore aggiunto io l'ho chiamato
l'appartenenza perché noi dobbiamo
essere orgogliosi di appartenere al
nostro territorio e di stare nel nostro
territorio
allora in questo caso vi racconto una
storiella che non è mia
le nostre ravera è una storiella che ha
raccontato piero calamandrei uno dei
padri della costituzione nel 1955 di
fronte aveva studenti universitari aveva
dei giovani e raccontò questa storia ci
sono due i migranti due persone semplici
inizi del 900 persone umili e decide di
andare via dall'italia
prendono queste grandi navi e partner 12
lanciato avuto il viaggio è sopra a
guardare il cielo l'altro in coperto in
fondo persone semplice tanto il viaggio
lui estasiato a guardare il cielo inizia
a diventare sempre più grigio asc le
onde più alte esserci più vento sempre
di più sempre di più la barca inizia a
muoversi sempre di più la gente inizia a
correre un certo punto incuriosito
spaventato anche inizia a chiedersi cosa
sta accadendo è fermo marina gli chiede
che cosa sta succedendo e maiello guarda
stupito fa ma non si rende conto la vede
la tempesta se continua così la nave
affonderà come colpito persona semplice
non era abituata a quello che stava
vedendo prende corre corre dal suo amico
da giuseppe in fondo dove lo trova
tranquillamente distesa nel suo letto ma
dietro la testa il sereno dice giuseppe
non ti rendi conto fuori c'è la tempesta
la nave rischia di affondare giuseppe
sereno lo guarda gli dice ma che mi
frega
la nave mi che mi ha il concetto di
appartenenza è legato anche al mondo
economico
se io non sono interessato a quello che
accade nel mio quartiere se non sono
interessato a quello che accade al punto
di vista economico nelle strade a fianco
se non sono interessato a quel 98.2 per
cento non faccio bene a me perché la
nave è sempre la stessa
grazie
[Applauso]